welcome back to the 64th ever episode of
the iced coffee hour
my name's ilya and the podcast so far
has made
seventy three thousand two hundred
eighty eight dollars and sixty three
cents
i think wow was the best introduction
we've actually ever had i don't know how
we pulled it off
yeah we did really good your enthusiasm
by the way it was a 10 out of 10.
timothy sykes was the only other guest
you had yeah
what do you mean are you [ __ ] kidding
me yeah i loved him
yes right where you're sitting right he
was sitting right there
what yeah yeah wow how do you know
timothy sykes uh dude i took his
um penny uh trading penny stock trading
course like the whole thing i paid for
it like i took the course and like
that's how i learned how to trade penny
stocks are you serious
did it work i mean i don't do it anymore
but when i did it yeah you did make
money
yeah so funny story timothy stanks for
me was someone who got me into stock
trading when i was like 13 14 years old
in high school
i saw one of his ads and how he turned
like you know his bar mitzvah money into
millions of dollars
i got really into penny stock trading
and for me he was just like
i looked up to him when i was like 14
years old yeah i ended up losing money
but it was weird meeting him in person
like so many years later yes he was the
one that got me into
he's such a real dude yeah he's such a
he does not give a [ __ ]
what he says no and it's great because
it's like so
transparent yeah and he came in with
that sort of energy like yeah
i'm thinking like is he on no that's
just he's always like a 10 out of 10
energy
no coffee it's just who he is he's so
excited he's very loud he's yelling the
entire i met him one time yeah and uh it
was in chicago
and i was like dude i love your energy
he's like yeah thanks it's the liquor
yeah i swear to god dude he didn't say
that i don't think
yeah i don't think he drinks i think
he's i don't think he drinks but i think
he may have just like been
on some on some shots or maybe he had
before that could very well be the case
yeah that's sick yeah yeah so yes we had
timothy sex sitting right there
wow so there you go you know who timothy
sykes is joking yeah i just looked him
up
yeah very cool very cool very good we
should introduce our guest yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah jack you want to do the
honor
sure so we have joe volpis over on the
left joe everyone
uh and we also have ilya federovich wow
is that how you pronounce it yeah
yeah thank you and uh you two have your
own podcast
the lightweights podcast yes where you
guys discuss
anything you guys want anything and
everything yeah it doesn't have to be uh
about investing or you know really any
topic it's standards are low over there
and you know what you actually had a
podcast previously the down bad podcast
no take notes oh take notes take notes
yeah my co-host then changed it to the
down bad pocket okay yeah the take notes
podcast
and we reached out to you oh and you
didn't get back to
people that we reached out to i
completely forgot you know what you
didn't even
like dm your your main account oh you
didn't
or the take notes podcast wait when did
you damn me or when did you need him
that account
i mean this has got to be a lot it was
probably like six seven months ago
because
that podcast was about business it was
supposed to be about business and i was
like okay
finally like we get to meet these guys
let's dm them so we can introduce
ourselves and get you know a little
change i think what happened was i i was
not
doing it anymore so i wasn't on the
account i wasn't on that instagram
account anymore
so i didn't see your message and the
reason i stopped doing is that i moved
to california
and my co-host obviously was still in
illinois and that's why i started
didn't you yeah i dm'd you yes you did
and then we didn't see it and we didn't
see it oh my god
it was so bad man we just missed each
other it's all good now we're here yeah
it's funny you dm me
like almost a year ago yeah i didn't see
the message
and then i sorted by like the the top
post yeah yours came up like oh crap
we missed you and then i dm you back and
then i think you didn't respond for a
little bit then we finally made it
happen yes
yeah now we're here though but all good
and now you're here and you just
finished up recording an episode for
your guys's podcast
and you had graham on you guys talked
business but we did you guys didn't talk
specific numbers like you guys do you
want to talk some numbers
please i want to know i want to know how
much money you're making and your
thoughts on investing personal finance
how much money you're saving where you
spend your money
you want to go first worst money yeah
your worst money decisions
my worst money is and then we want to
know anything else anything else crazy
like we want to hear crazy stories
anything else you want to bring up just
in recently you want the nutty the
nuttiest stuff that you have
in recent i spent 20 500 on a makeup job
that me and elia were going to do for a
video
but we ended up not doing the video so
now we're going to do this makeup video
maybe never i don't know but that was a
waste of money
you did 2 500 for makeup yeah what was
the initial idea for the video we were
going to get dressed up as like
a couple of old dudes and i don't know
what we were going to do with it but
everyone is making that video
aren't they the old dude yeah carter
sharar just did that he did a gold
digger
on girlfriend video with his uh mclaren
or his lamborghini
yeah oh yeah well good thing we didn't
do it yeah well that's why we didn't do
it because i didn't want to follow the
trend
uh my worst money decision
personally has been i think um well i
don't know
it depends like if we're talking about
being stupid and like gambling i lost 10
grand on black
in roulette oh we bet our entire bank
account oh my god you guys gotta [ __ ]
hear the story it's
insane so we're in we're in vegas joe
and i maybe like two months ago
and we're sitting at dinner i'm like
let's bet our entire bank account on
roulette and at the time we've paid we
paid ourselves out and we only had like
three and a half maybe four grand in
there
and he's like all right whatever so i
was like let's do green
let's let's bet on green because there's
black there's red oh wait how much was
it
uh three thousand thirty five hundred
five hundred yeah but now if you would
hit green you would have made 36 times
that yeah it's like a hundred and eight
thousand dollars
like that but listen that's crazy so
i'm like let's buy green he's like no
either black or red i could because
you know my green i was like oh come on
let's do it if we're gonna do let's do
green
he's like no so i forget black and he's
like all right black
so we go to the table and well no he's
not even there he's not even there he's
like
he's like 100 meters away because he
doesn't want to witness about
what's about to happen we also did it
while we were recording a podcast so we
took a break
we went downstairs to the lobby and i
said you go do it and then you come back
and tell me that way i could react to
what happened so i go
i go to i go to the table and
everyone has their [ __ ] on black so i'm
like it's gotta hit black so i put it on
black
it spins and it doesn't land black i'm
like it landed red and then i look up
and it's blinking double zero green no
swear to god
bro and you know how there's zero and
double zero i specifically told him i'm
like double zero green
yeah he didn't even say green he didn't
say singles he said double zero green
the entire time
and dude i'm walking over to him i think
it's gonna hit green you know like you
just
have a feeling like it's instinctual
like it was like that it was so weird
but here's the thing though i always
think this way
the extra time it would have taken you
to like go and say
double zero or whatever that extra split
second that he put the thing
he might have spend it differently maybe
i agree with grant turned out like for
every second there's a whole different
there's a whole bunch of variables that
are changing
brings out so many good points right
there and i basically
make you still feel better no i agree
yeah i do agree that there may have been
something
anyways so that was that was the worst
money you've ever i mean no the worst
money i spent was
i lost 10 grand at roulette um and that
was just again i'm black i always do
black
or green but um yeah i lost 10 grand
that was like a split second like that
and that's all at once yeah why um
i don't know someone was like you should
bet a thousand and i was like
a thousand sounds cool but ten thousand
sounds really cool so
it's more cool for sure yeah but but but
the thing is if i would have won
then i would have had an additional ten
thousand dollars like that you know what
i mean so it's like
there's a positive and there's a
negative outcome since you lost were you
compelled at all
to double it up and just do two yeah
next time i'm gonna do i'm gonna do 20.
you're gonna do 20 yeah what happens if
you lose that he's gonna double it from
there again
yeah i'm gonna double every time until i
win it kind of works a little bit yeah i
go i go to the casinos and i'll get on
like the electronic computer one and you
can do small amounts in there and i'll
do the double up method
and it does tend to work until it
doesn't but like in the beginning it
works and you make some money so you
lose your whole bank account yeah the
house edge is going to take over there's
going to be that one percent
where you're just going to keep going
indefinitely and then the issue with
that though is you hit maximums like
those tables are going to have a maximum
so probably on roulette uh it's going to
be 20 grand
so the next time you go 20 grand if you
lose that you can't
go and do a 40 000 bet i think there's
high high uh i think
they're called high rollers the high
stakes the high stakes stops 20 25
000 oh really yeah oh that [ __ ] stuff
unless unless you make prior
accommodation unless you're a whale
going to vegas like gambling like a
million dollars they'll make
accommodations for you but almost
always even the vip rooms it's 20 000
that's the limit
they don't want people going to vegas
putting fifty thousand dollars in one
hand
winning and be like right right i'm done
that's bad for business they want you to
keep playing multiple hands
they know every hand you play their
chances of getting their money
go higher so they want to avoid just one
off like here's money so we gotta go
there with at least a hundred thousand
dollars
and then leave yes i'm learning
something there and win the 20
000. if you lose the 20 000 it's gonna
be harder to double up 40.
well we happen to be out in las vegas so
if you want to do that i would love to
come down and watch this stick
yeah yeah i know 100 we should do it
this week
you know what i don't remember this week
but no next week wait wait we'll be
there
so you booked a ticket to hawaii just
just yourself
not yet i'm thinking about it you're
thinking about it okay yeah i really
wanted to surprise elliot one day with
an instagram story and he's like you
went to hawaii without me because i owe
him a trip
whoa what are we doing here graham what
are you doing here
this is my house oh uh well what's that
in your hand
it's my phone no no no no that oh
this is the free stock i just got from
public using the link down below in the
description because guess what when you
sign up and you use the code gram
you could get a free stock worth all the
way up to seventy dollars
seventy dollars seventy dollars and plus
when you deposit a hundred dollars on
the platform you're going to be entered
for a chance to win a
totally free share of tesla by july 12th
that right now is trading at almost 700
wait can you show me how that works it's
really easy when you sign up and you use
the code gram you'll automatically get a
free stock when you sign up and i got
this stock right here let's see what it
is
46 of amazon that's amazing that's
incredible all right guys well if you
want a chance to get a free stock too
the link is down below in the
description let me know which free stock
you get and with that said let's get
back to the video
we made a bet in a call of duty game if
we got first
and we ended up getting first so now i
owe him a trip to hawaii play warzone no
no yeah okay so you know how hard it is
to get first place in general sure so
this is our first game of the night like
when you're usually getting warmed up
and like you're not that good
this is our first game of the night and
i was like joe
we get first place you have to buy me
tickets to hawaii and we fly out and we
end up getting first
first game it's like again it's like
impossible to do ellie always says these
ridiculous things when we were at the
aquarium he goes
what are the odds i jumped in the tank
i'm like i can't play this game with you
because you're gonna do it
so you guys play odds yeah no uh like
like one in one yeah
yeah of course yeah you play no you were
two who was telling me about odds
uh i'm not sure well let's do it right
now you wanna do odds okay let's do it
yeah yeah
what are the odds you're gonna do this
you you bet this one
uh yeah
and then you say the thing right right
right um what are the odds you put a
thousand dollars in doji coin right now
i wait i tell you or you say yeah
[Laughter]
yeah you say like if if you're like okay
i could do this one in ten or if you're
like i don't really want to do this one
in a hundred or
i'm definitely not doing this one in a
thousand you want me to tell you what i
would do
well no yeah what are the odds like one
and a hundred i'll do that
okay and now we say one two three and we
both say the number
that we're both thinking guess a number
and then if we both say the exact number
you have to do it out of my seat
so i'm going to say so i'm going to
think of a number we both say
if we say that number i'm going to
invest right now yeah a thousand dollars
in dodge
but usually it's one in 10. yeah you
don't usually do it you don't do it
because yes because 100 is just like
such a yeah there's no point is
by not investing in dogecoin jack bought
dogecoin a hundred dollars
how much you sell it for like 13 and a
half thousand
jack did well i've been telling jack you
gotta sell it he got us he told me i
should have sold at like five thousand
dollars wait you haven't sold yet
no i did oh you did okay wow i told him
he's gotta take that now
and buy back in cheaper i'm going to i'm
going to buy it back but i'm saving up a
little bit right now should we do it one
of the odds
for me to buy we should 110. okay
all right i think dogecoin yeah i feel
like we should come up with something
like like active like
dodge made jack a lot of money so why
would i re-dip
into that right you want our audience
our audience we do something new here
our audience is investing
[Laughter]
something new here oh my god someone's
gonna hit somebody
it's always great seeing like what are
the odds you do something new
what do you uh what are they one and
five what is something right so let's do
it you and i
what is that
make me
if we hit the same number you could do
whatever investment you want if we don't
it's you're investing in dogecoin
wait wait yes what are the odds you do
something new what do you guys think
about this do you think there's
something better that we could do
i think i think that there's something
better i think there's something like
what are the odds like do you have a
pool here
no we have the ocean it's pretty close
um
don't make them run to the other side
i'm not gonna make it run at you um
that's actually it's gotta be something
you can do on camera let's do this oh do
you have anything hot here
like really hot peppers no oh uh spicy
hot yes no spicy
uh i might have like some hot sauce or
something
okay it's boring that works no no no
it'll work i think because if you fill
up the hot sauce like that much
when i said this i was trying to keep it
like stock business related for their
theme
i wanted to do something where like the
loser of out of us four would have to
take it like a shot of hot sauce yes
perfect
okay let's do it two grams like
[Laughter]
okay what do you think i like dogecoin
but it's up to you i'll let you you pick
i mean you know what you want to do i
want you to
use the worst influence yeah i want to
do the hot sauce
i break them up okay all right
for the sake program we'll do the
dogecoin okay okay all right uh
one in ten okay who who we all say a
number or what no so it's between two
people
all right i'll let you you guys go okay
let's practice you and ice and then so
you can do it together with him it's
like
let's say you can just do it let's say
just do a jack because you're already
you already have the ethereum stuff set
up so if we get the same thing then i
have to invest in dodge coin if i
if we don't then and it goes both ways
so if i do it then he's got to do it to
me too
okay sure yeah yeah all right who's this
for who's this for first jack
jack 110 dogecoin okay thousand dollars
wait but if we get the same number i
have to do ditch coin if it's a
different number i do whatever i want
with a thousand yes
okay all right all right one two
three ten okay
[Music]
okay i don't know i don't need any more
excitement i got enough excitement
no no i i got you but i mean sometimes
it's fun like i'll tell joe be like joe
i was one of them you jump to the pool
with your clothes on and like
obviously he doesn't want to do it and i
want him to do it because it's funny
but why we play is because there's a
chance of him most likely not doing it
it's just a really small chance of him
doing it you know sure one time we did
100
two times um in a row and we got that
number was like 64 and then 67 or
something like that
one of them was it was like in
wintertime it was really cold outside
and i mean i had them he had to jump in
the pool with the clothes on
um and it sounds really stupid but
but i explained it um jump in the pool
with the clothes on no not like your
favorite
thing you have a pool here
no it's just yeah
what was it what was the second one that
you did then the 64 66 or whatever
scott scott was doing a music video my
friend scott my friend scott was doing a
music video
in his backyard and i uh he joe's like i
was 100
you ruined the music video by like
by like destroying all the lights
[Laughter]
yeah anyways um that was that you ruined
it no no i didn't i didn't
so you didn't oh i didn't obey it that
was the one time i've
i have not obeyed it and then he
actually ended up not jumping in the
pool
so now we're even and now we have to
continue obeying it but i'm like pretty
like with the words and odds like i
which one's more important to you that
what's that okay so that's just like
it's like it's like it's when you say
like are you sure are you honest honest
honest yeah it's like it's like honest
but it's like it's like a religion it's
like
like okay you you tell me that you just
look at grab space he's just like
i don't know you tell me that you just
made a million dollars off of a house
and i go dead
and you go yeah that meaning like yeah
i'm being honest
yeah but you can't break that because if
you break that out then like you just
lied to me
like it's like very like very powerful
why aren't you dead
just deeper than yeah like why can't you
just say like
for real like really yeah it's like for
real but you know why why are serious
because when you say for real you can
like put the person a lie but you say
that's like you cannot lie at that ass
yeah we honor it so much over at our
podcast
i have something like that with my best
friend that we've had since we were like
six we call it bros
and basically you cannot lie if you say
bros and
we've done that for like 15 years where
you just have to honor it
because there are some things that you
really need to know the answer to and
you just
you gotta pull it out dude we all sound
so dark in fairness
in fairness i don't really honor dennis
i lie on it all the time ellie gets
really bad with that do you really
yeah oh man that's not one of us
because it ruffles his feathers so much
yeah but don't lie to me don't land
bro see i'm so confused
all right so how much money do you guys
make a month
or a year yeah yeah i like a month a
month is good a month yeah because it
varies i'm sure we could infer a year
from that
i mean how it's broken down so the only
though
i've uh revenue streams right now it's
my plumbing business
um the podcast and
investments right so like off of like
stock investments and
and like crypto and random [ __ ] like
that um
maybe fifty thousand dollars a year so
not a ton of money
that's pretty that's good now are we
talking uh stock appreciation or we're
talking like
dividends like fifty thousand dollars no
stock appreciation so buy sell because i
swing trade right i do
okay yeah i don't really invest long
term more like are you in a stock group
or something or do you just figured out
your own no i just figured out i mean
most i i it was just like intuition and
learning from people like timothy sykes
sure wall street bets wall street bans
no actually um
i've i just found out about wall street
bets like a month ago online oh yeah
yeah it's a life changer
it's a great community yeah it really is
um
from the podcast i don't know we make
wait wait a second alex why are you here
i mean i i work here
no why are you here in the video
you know i'm not really sure wait did
you get your free stock yet
no oh come on
what are you doing that's why we're here
right now you gotta get your free stock
down below in the description it's worth
all the way up to seventy dollars
seventy dollars seventy dollars and if
you want a chance to get a totally free
share of tesla
all you gotta do is sign up and deposit
a hundred dollars on the platform
using the code gram gram gram
g-r-a-h-a-m
and where is this link again down below
in the description or you could go to
public.com
gram it's super easy it'll take you just
a few minutes and best of all you should
probably do it now before you forget
you know what i'm gonna do it right now
you promised i promise
do you guys promise to otherwise we're
just gonna keep appearing in the video
and you don't want that to happen
just do it guys thanks so much now with
that said let's get back to the video
each like 5 000 a month a little more
yeah um so again like not a ton there
but it's still pretty cool yeah
i'm making money that's cool um and then
off my plumbing business it depends on
how well it does that year and like
what i'm reinvesting um
for the first like three four years
basically all that i made i reinvested
back into the business
um and i'm still doing that somewhat
maybe like not as much as before but
i think if i wanted to i can take a
profit of uh
maybe like five to six hundred thousand
a year uh my plumbing
i didn't know you had a plumbing
business yeah is this you knew this
judge
yeah but i didn't know it made that much
money yeah well my appointment business
makes
uh three million a year revenue
yeah revenue i had no idea i figured
because i i knew you had the business
but i figured i was like
maybe makes like a hundred grand because
i knew that you've used that to like
allow yourself to move out wait a second
let's let's go back on this because
i'm new to this i don't know about the
plumbing business how did how did you
start this walk us through this
so i started um back in 2015 i think
with my dad
and what happened was he had a new
construction company
new construction plumbing company and
when i came in i said let's do just
service so service meaning like
selling water heaters and fixing faucets
and like
fixing super problems that you that
every home has um
and we started with with one person it
was me my dad and one other employee
and we grew it to um pre-covet it was 36
people
wow yeah so um
unfortunately i unfortunately
unfortunately left you know for other
opportunities in california but
um yeah so you're still involved in that
business yeah
not as much as uh as i used to be but i
mean it used to be like
14 hours a day of my life you know for
five six years
that's one of the things i talk about
all the time people people uh overlook
trade schools
i think being a plumber an electrician a
lot of these these careers
can make a lot of money without any
student loan debt
they're affordable they're in demand
there will always be demand for a
plumber
yeah even if people are working from
home if if people are not going to
offices anymore it doesn't matter
plumbing is always going to be a thing
it's always breaking i actually just had
an issue recently with this toilet
again dude running issues down there oh
the the
sink leaks the the toilet doesn't flush
yeah dude yeah man well since when
i don't know it just it i just think i
could take a look at it
oh yeah you fixed my toilet the other
day could you actually yeah
holy cow let's do that yeah we can do
that after this we'll vlog it
we'll do that after this yeah but yeah
this is news to me i told jack
uh not to flush because he's flushing
like every time he pees
i told him like he doesn't need to do
that you just
leave it leave it throughout the day if
it's yellow let it mellow if it's now
flush it down right and i told him that
so it's a game changer for jack
because i'm paying the water bill the
water i pay the water i don't want to
have to pay the water for jack to be
flushing all the time if he's drinking
all these all these uh sparkling waters
but i didn't know that it's not
i just it's it's bigger it's bigger than
just a flush what did you flush
me i didn't flush anything i said alex
i don't want to point any fingers so so
going back to uh
the skilled trades yes there's there's
really not
many people in the trades world that are
good
and by good i mean clean proficient on
time
drug free there's really not um
and it's it's really really really hard
to grow
a trade business like plumbing because
out of every 10 people that you hire to
be a plumber
nine of them turn out to be bad uh
either
oh dude i hired a plumber or at least i
thought it was a plumber off taskrabbit
the other day
dude did not speak english didn't say
that on the listing
and then when i asked him to fix the
shower head which is what it was
he's like no fix i'm like what do you
mean
he's like no fix like what does that
mean so i literally called ilya
because turns out they both spoke
russian and elia was talking to the guy
through facetime trying to tell him what
to do
and then it was like uh call me back
once he leaves like okay turns out i
i don't even know what happened going
back to what you said about
about materials appreciating yeah and
being more expensive
i think the same thing is gonna happen
with with tradesmen and women
i think because there's such a lack of
people there's such a lack of supply of
those people yeah
hourly rates are going to be
skyrocketing in the next 10 years i
think
you'll be paying like honestly two times
more for a plumber than you are now
unless you get someone like
inexperienced or a handyman but if
you're talking a licensed plumber in a
state like california illinois new york
where a license is required i mean
you'll be paying like
150 200 an hour easy for a plumber you
know it's crazy
lawyers like like cheaper lawyers maybe
about 85 to 125 an hour good lawyers
like 500 an hour
you're paying almost half of what is
required from a
law school why is it so expensive to get
licensed
so it depends on the state yeah uh
california again illinois and new york
are the toughest states to get licensed
in
and it requires a four-year
apprenticeship
right so you're you're an apprentice
under a licensed plumber for four years
and once that four years is over you go
to your state exam and it's
really [ __ ] hard why they just they
don't [ __ ] around with that
it's like it's it's your safety it's
your health you know like if you think
about it
right other states don't get like
georgia florida like they'll fix your
plumbing for a root beer you know what i
mean like
no seriously but in in states of
california illinois they do not [ __ ]
around like you have to be
up to par for your plumbing your it has
to be correct and if a health inspector
catches a non-licensed plumber
if you're a nine licensed plumber you're
fixing someone's plumbing that's a big
[ __ ] problem for you was my guy
non-licensed no he was not licensed what
did he say to you i mean he was just uh
he was just i don't even know what he
was i don't know how he took apart the
[ __ ] shower valve or the plate
whatever
but he made it worse the the leaky
shower
so you paid him and he made it worse
yeah i bought it on taskrabbit and
he's this is a topic i want to talk to
joe about why the
did you hire a plumber on taskrabbit
what do you mean because
where else am i going to hire a plumber
yeah a plumbing company
i i i just did taskrabbit it said
plumber he was five stars he had a
hundred reviews
um okay well anyways if you're looking
for a plumber you have to hire a
licensed professional that knows what
he's doing or he can way worse
yeah way worse than it was before i'd
rather i'd rather pay
i'd rather have you pay 500 versus 100
but he does it one time does it right
and no wow
i had no idea that's what i believe
honestly trade schools man yeah i think
trade schools
so many people just i guess it's not
it's not glamorized but i'm hearing
stories
like see right but i'm hearing stories
about plumbers now making like you know
150 000
a year running a business i think is
where the money is really to be made
maybe
you work as a plumber the first few
years first four you get licensed work
you know work with a company and start
your own yeah i mean even if you start
your own company as a as a plumber you
don't have to have a ton of people to
make a ton of money you know
if you i know a lot of people that run
out of their truck they have maybe
one two people they don't have any
overhead they don't have any staff they
don't have a huge warehouse they don't
have to worry about i can keep in stock
like
all that bullet that i have to deal with
i wish i didn't you know what i mean but
obviously i do it because i want to grow
it to like
no where does that 200 an hour go let's
say 150 an hour
why is it so high where does that money
all go
because the plumber is getting paid 40
to 50 sometimes even upwards of 60 an
hour
just a plumber right then you got to
consider travel
and you got to consider the car right
the car obviously
breaks down i gotta pay gas for it then
you gotta consider inventory in the car
like there's just so many
variables just to even get to your home
that cost me money like
honestly it costs me on average about
80 bucks just to get to your home wow
just to just can arrive and then on top
of that obviously
he's there he's using material and again
that depends on
how like a water heater for example is
500 bucks alone
you know so like it just it all depends
on something i never thought about uh
why they always have the trade call fees
like 65 dollars just to come out and
take a look and tell me what's wrong
with you people don't make money on that
it makes sense
i never thought about that yeah yeah so
i mean you have to have it and companies
that don't have it
like i didn't have it for the first two
years i think or three years and then i
was like
that i'm done eating these costs because
it like this just does not help people
just come and you'd be like oh this is
broken all right thanks and then
exactly how do i fix that and that's all
right on top of that you got to realize
that if you're paying you're already
in you know what i mean so you might as
well go the extra mile and just get it
done if you don't pay anything you have
nothing to lose so if someone comes
you're like ah
i'm good too expensive i'll get someone
else and then that someone else ends up
coming
pricing it higher and they're like i
might as well get it done
you know what i mean so that's a
significant amount of money for five
hundred
six five hundred thousand dollars a year
yeah i mean but
so why aren't you taking that as a sound
is it you just don't need the money
right now it's not worth it to be taxed
you know what i realized alex
that you're wearing two different kinds
of socks yes but you know what else
oh what we could just sponsor ourselves
in this video how about that you know
what that sounds great i always like my
own posts anyway
me too and for a limited time if you
want access to the youtube creator
academy where i go over exactly what you
need to do step by step to start a
youtube channel and turn it into a
business
i will give you 200 off when you use the
coupon code
200 off the link is down below in the
description this is everything that i
have learned about how to grow a youtube
channel what makes a successful title
and thumbnail everything you need to do
along the way
it's all down below in the description
and it's 200 off
200 bucks off 200. but
i'm going to take you up on that deal
because i have this to family to run
wow there we go well thank you guys so
much for watching enjoy the discount and
with that said let's get back to the
video
business it's better to be in the
business okay yeah for sure
have you ever said that before have i
ever said that number yeah um
no i don't think so i mean i told joe
but we told each other how much we make
on our first podcast and we meant to
bleep it out
and then we forgot to bleep it out but
now it's bleeped out
see it's opposite for us i'm always so
open about it well i guess with personal
finance i like i try to lead by example
and say like here's
how much money i'm making here's from
where i'm breaking it down because i
think just people are curious and and uh
it kind of scratches that itch because
i'm always wondering like in my mind
how much money they make everybody i'm
just i'm just curious
you look like a kid at a candy store
like how much money are you doing
i'm just wondering it just scratches
that itch for me and i just i like
talking about it what's your what's your
like goal
amount per year that you'd like to make
where you know
and this is kind of hard to answer
because
you can hit that goal and then you'll be
like nah that's not enough right but it
right now what's your goal like what do
you want to be making per year
profit i i mean unless there's a yeah
pre-test goal or
how much i need goal goal uh
pre-tax probably 10 million a year
that's my number really yeah
yeah i think 10 million is like a very
comfortable
comfortable spot yeah yeah that's it i
just i just wanted to hit that
that amount that's 10 million in a year
totally yeah that's cool
me too jack what's yours my goal how
much
i said jack's probably you're either 500
000 or a million
yeah honestly i would be like how much
do i want to live off of or
like no what's your goal you gotta you
gotta get a goal what's your next
goal right uh my next goal oh yeah are
we taking next goals or what are we just
the goal
what's the goal like life goal uh i
would love to make
yeah like a million dollars in a year
that would be pretty that'd be good
yeah it's a nice lifestyle yeah in a
year for sure
um a cool goal would be like 5 million
i think that'd be really fun it's
interesting to think how many people
do make that amount and it makes you
like really think like okay if they can
do it like why can't i
have the exact same resources that they
have are they smarter than me you know
what i mean like
and sometimes the answer is yes but like
how much smarter you know
so it's once you get into those uh
there's this
circles or those friends groups you
realize like it's not how common it is
but it's like it's it
it's possible there's so many people did
you know there were 22
000 people who filed their tax returns
22 000 who reported over 10 million
a year in the u.s 22
000 people now when you think that there
are 300 million people it's a small
amount
but when you really put like just
imagine 22 000 people out there
that's a lot of people there's a lot of
people getting a lot of people making a
lot of money
yeah i think uh right now is the most
amount of millionaires that we've had
ever in the united states i don't know
how many it is but it's the most
yes part of that's due to inflation just
over time we're going to get way more
millionaires it's going to be a lot more
common and then also with the stock
market yep
if the stock market went down 50 we'd
have a lot fewer of them but i think
with the stock market real estate values
especially real estate values
for sure so what about you joe how about
how much do you make per month
um it's different with youtube each
month the higher
ad rates in like december and the big
time that's when the
they're advertising so it will i mean
over uh i did well with
you uh snapchat spotlight
the uh spotlight i made over over 200
000.
no yeah are you serious um
you got the finance police after yeah
the cops are outside
over over four months wow i was really
intense with it
whole like not that i stopped youtube
but that it was like
wait yeah explain this snapchat
spotlight
was basically snapchat gave away a
million dollars every day
to creators you didn't have to have a
platform you didn't have to have
followers you didn't have to have
anything
and when i first found out about it it's
you get a certain feeling of like this
is
something i need to hold on to it and
that's what i got from that because i
saw the content that was making money
i'm like i could do this but
way better so i basically stopped
filming as much youtube videos as i was
i was doing three videos a week i've
done it every day for the past every
week for the past three years four years
three non-stop never missed one and then
i was the same as me
exactly so three a week you know how
much that's a lot of work a lot of work
a lot of times
plus i shoot an edit for so many other
people and
it was at the point two of like with
covenant and whatnot i was like you know
what i'll just do one video
a week keep the channel alive and just
focus on snapchat spotlight
because that's what was going to make
the most money
more than advertisers more than whatever
more than sponsors anything
and i literally would just sit there
every single day
and you can upload a new video every
five minutes and that's what i would do
i would sit there
in front of my tv have a show on in the
background not
not texting anybody i'd wait set my
timer every five minutes and i'd upload
a new video
what videos are you uploading um they're
just like
kind of like tick tocks but they're not
really as
juicy content it's just like it's more
instagram stories
if you say can you tell them about how
um
you would you would like make stories up
oh
yeah so ultimately the content
you just try and make something that's
as like viral as possible
so i'd go film like a hundred dollars
in a bush and be like holy crap i can't
believe i just found this and that's a
video right there and then five minutes
the timer resets and then you gotta make
another video
and 100 somewhere else and then like i
put i'd put a candy bar in the sofa and
i'd be like my son
is hiding his food in my couch and
that's a video right there
and like the tear for like what it was
i'm insane dude it it i don't want to
say it was
i don't know like you just need to make
as as
click-baity i guess as a video as you
can and how many would you upload per
day
literally from morning till night every
five minutes so if you what is it
uh it's gotta be like thirty forty fifty
videos a day like seventy a day yeah
yeah i didn't take that many videos
though yeah that's some
yeah just non-stop and then you could
save and then you can re-upload
uh again like the next day or in a few
days wait a second so you take the same
videos and repost them the next day yeah
but once it hits in the algorithm it
doesn't work anymore
i think i don't know the rules have
changed so much in the past i don't do
it anymore um
it doesn't work as well as it did wow
why did you stop doing snapchat
spotlight why did i win why
um honestly it opened it up to a lot
more countries
and in the beginning it was just like 12
countries in the united states that's
our jobs
yeah and then so the
pool for success just really got a lot
smaller
yeah huh york stock parker on
southparkstudios.com
i used to yeah all the free episodes
yeah i've seen every single south park
episode probably into the last like two
seasons three seasons that
i just haven't gotten around to watching
isn't that crazy that they just upload
them for free yep
that's so bizarre parker and matt stone
they would be idols of mine if i ever
met them in person do you know how they
got that
what do you know how they got the south
park studios no oh
this is free i don't okay so way back
when
that could be completely wrong but way
back when they were making their
contract with comedy central
they negotiated the terms where they get
all the ownership rights to the internet
and at the time the internet wasn't
really a thing nobody watched stuff on
the internet
so when they made the episodes comedy
central got all the network
ad rates whatever but matt stone and
trey parker got
all the control over the internet so
that's why those episodes just go up
right away like no ads they make the
money on the website
that's really you should look look more
into it because i'm like i'm probably
just grazing over like what really
happened but they ended up getting all
the rights from like the beginning of
the show because the internet wasn't
that popular back then
gosh i would love to me there's someone
i want to meet at some point
yeah would love to meet have you ever
seen them record like you've seen those
types of them recording
not the tick tocks i've seen the youtube
videos behind the scenes yeah it's
[ __ ] hilarious
it's incredible how they work and a lot
of these episodes are done like the week
of
and they film current events and they
just churn out these episodes
and they're all good i don't think the
quality has degraded
they've softened a little bit from the
very beginning those first few seasons
but
the quality is still there i think
unfortunately unlike the simpsons which
i think
got a little bit too mainstream after
maybe season five or six i just stopped
watching them but south park has
maintained it
yeah really well they're just as
relevant today as they were in the 90s
yeah but it's crazy do you still watch
it graham i do
every episode not every episode i
haven't seen the last few seasons but
sometimes in the car if we if maybe in a
road trip to
vegas on the way we'll we'll put on a
south park episode in the car
huh on your tesla yeah and then auto
drive uh no
unfortunately as you're charging you
could watch an episode yeah
i wish i wish they would allow at least
part of the screen like the right side
of the screen yeah to play a movie or
something while you're driving
have you guys seen the show with a
hundred no goddamn it
elliott brings that up to everybody i
mean it's just like it's
it's good it's good yeah the the concept
of the show is that
earth is uninhabitable and they send 100
people down from the space station 100
kids
excuse me down to the space station or
down to earth from the space station
to see if they can um to see if earth is
livable
and the story goes on from there but
yeah it's really good
i haven't seen it i have not seen 100
but i will watch it's like
the only reason i bring it up is because
i finished like two uh
two tv shows ever and it was the hundred
and breaking bad
oh did you finish breaking bad yeah you
like it i couldn't do it man what
oh come on dude it got so bad
here's the deal man i've started
breaking bad at least five times at
least five times and i can't finish it
every single time
well are you stuck on that one episode
maybe you should just skip it
i don't know which episode you're stuck
in the fly episode you just move on
circular answer or circle the thing that
you think you think sounds like
yeah there's the breaking bad house in
new mexico we went there
so did i did you see the owners uh no
but they had the big fence out front
dude they got pissed because back then
people would throw pizzas on the roof
like it happened in the episode
but now there's so many tick tocks of
owners coming out and just like flipping
off the camera hey how about this
move out that's what you get breaking
bad house why are you still there yeah
everything they've done their best they
changed the roof so it doesn't look like
the same roof they changed the landscape
they changed the paint in front they've
tried to make it
they should demolish that but you know
what i i would have sold it because yeah
because someone would have paid
someone's
premium there's some weird reason why
they're staying there or maybe
obviously just like maybe they're
cooking something up in the garage
they could be drug dealers or they could
just love the attention i didn't love
the attention but i did the whole
breaking bad tour
in uh in new mexico did you go to
chicken place uh yeah i went to the
chicken place
what's it called the car wash pollo loco
or no is that
yeah yeah mcdonald's no i went to all
the places where um
saul goodman's spot was that little like
strip mall wow
i visited every spot down there that's
cool yeah i have pictures of going
through all those places it was a
highlight
day the highlight of the trip that's
cool
do you guys want to talk about investing
yeah i do i love investing
yeah all right what are you invested in
uh currently i'm invested
only in doji only in doji are you really
yeah no that's what i got only how much
um
i think 12 000. that's that's all you're
investing yeah well for now
i mean no no but you were but you were
saying that you were making like 50
grand a year
yeah trading so um in the beginning of
last year when we had that huge dip um i
prior to that
it was not in the market at all and then
i
bought in um i think
like honestly at the very lowest point i
think what my my stocks were
spirit american um there's like a ton of
airlines and then
um caesar entertainment penn national
gaming
um and i sold that i think it made like
200 on all of those
um and once i sold that i got into
crypto and i've been swing trading
crypto but
the past month or so i've only been in
doge doji whatever
but why don't you invest more than
twelve thousand dollars considering your
income
um i don't know i just haven't got
around to it honestly i just haven't
like where else does the money go
if it's just dogecoin where does it
where does it stop clubs yes
i don't know if i were your financial
advisor i'd be like you cut that you cut
that out well yeah bro trust me if you
were my financial advisor you would not
be my 5.
you would quit wait so what else is
number three like what what what would
be
no just like food post mates
yeah unfortunately i spent a lot of
money on that's one thing like i would
love to cut back on but i just can't
because it's just
it's so easy to to order food from like
a
third-party delivery app like doordash i
spend probably like three grand a month
on food
see at that point it really would make
sense because you live with people right
yeah to hire a chef chef yes it does
how much is a chef chef probably not
more than that no
and you could get like hot food whenever
you want three meals a day
and they bring the food no they would
cook they cook it at your place
but i mean they buy the food or that's
on top of the well i'm sure they pay for
the food yeah they'll just basically
come like a lot of these
uh chef services will come like three
times a week and they'll meal prep so
they'll make you food for like the next
three days
wow eat it it could be healthy too yeah
yeah yeah totally oh i'm gonna do that
i'm sure if you did that with your other
roommates and stuff like that housemates
you could probably get a pretty good
deal on like a private chef and just
yeah oh for sure that i mean that's
actually one thing that i i praise joe
on he doesn't spend money
on stupid really at all unless i like
make him yeah he really convinces me to
do it but does that mean you're
investing your money uh i
i always saved i was taught to save so
you just fill up your bank account
and then recently i did the whole stocks
and portfolios but now i
started switching out to do real estate
well real estate's
yeah that's good yeah so what's your
goal with real estate
is it to get a certain dollar amount or
just keep buying houses buy a few houses
a year what's
um get that financial freedom you know
what's that to you
i don't know like 20 grand a month at
least okay
yeah for real estate yeah all like
profit where like everything's paid off
and i just have like 20 cash
play money but i'd love to just keep
like uh investing
i'd love to have like 10 by the end of
next year
yeah they're like collecting pokemon
it's fun yeah
how much is that property cash flowing
the one that i just got
in arizona i've i've literally just
closed on it like two weeks ago
but in the summer months i'm gonna be at
a loss probably of like 200
a month but in the winter months you
could be at a profit of like two three
four thousand dollars a month
because it's your airbnb oh you're
airbnb yeah yeah yeah so like
because the winter months in arizona
that's when all the snowbirds go and
that's when
no one wants to be there in the summer
when it's 117 degrees why not just find
a year-long tenant
i was thinking that but a lot less work
like overall wouldn't it be about
about the same averaged out throughout
the year not as much
and you probably know more than me about
it but from what i figured it's like
you'd cat you make more putting more
effort into it but if you just hire the
right property management company then
they'll do all the work anyway
so what am i really doing at the end of
the day other than answering a phone
call saying yeah
just replace this wear and tear i agree
yeah
but it i haven't
failed at that yet so i haven't had the
need to be like i'm just gonna do a
year-long tenant
i'm about simplicity you get a tenant in
for a year
you might make 20 less but you just that
peace of mind they're in there
no issues yes but i keep asking people
who do do it to see their numbers and
when they show me their numbers i'm like
oh i'll just do this
because at the end of the day i'm a
youtuber and i want to do podcasts so i
want to focus on that and then i'll just
use that to funnel the money into the
real estate
the lady who used to own this house here
she was renting at the guesthouse in
airbnb
and she was earning like 70 grand a year
wow guest house
are you doing that now no that's you
have the guesthouse someone lives there
yeah
it was it was it was jack nice jack's
not living there anymore
so maybe maybe at some point i'm not
gonna airbnb because in order to airbnb
you have to be a full-time
occupant in this house you have to be
here 100 of the time so i checked i'm
like
if if i own this as you know just a
secondary house can i still no
right i'm strict very strict in
california extremely strict about it so
i can't i wouldn't risk it
and they and they will sometimes check
up on you too oh really
yeah they actually sent the letter to uh
to making sure that i wasn't renting out
that guest house
i gave it the jack it's just it's a part
of the business that we run
but yeah they were checking because a
lot of people will rent like under the
table
and so they will check to see that
people aren't trying to skirt around
them
wow i don't understand because so your
money where does your money just sit
because yeah i mean another system a
bank account i either invested
reinvested
materials purchased equipments purchased
that obviously
is for my plumbing company you know so i
mean some of the equipment's super
expensive
now that you moved here how much time do
you spend doing your plumbing company
a week i mean i when i lived in chicago
it was like maybe 90 hours a week 80
hours a week
wow but now it's like maybe 10.
and you passed it off to who i mean
there's people that have work in the
company that passed on like all of my
responsibilities too
over time so do you give up equity in
order to do that or is it like a salary
like you're paying somebody else's
salary
okay yeah um yeah so
that's impressive i'm honestly i'm
really impressed yeah that's that's
really incredible thank you i have no
idea
we're all impressed yeah
yeah thank you i appreciate it i
remember i was listening to
some podcasts i don't know if it was
like your guys podcast reviews
but you said that you used to give
really lavish gifts to your
to your ex-girlfriend oh my god yeah so
yeah that's like another thing that i
have uh unfortunately when i meet like a
girl or something
yeah like i don't know it's really
not when i wish i didn't do this stupid
but like whenever i meet a girl just
like buy something really dumb like a
purse for like two grand or
and something really [ __ ] stupid that
will never ever
ever be a return on my investment
because i'll probably never talk to the
girl again
you know how soon like i'm talking like
first date second date
relationship um i don't know like i've
had to like
i would have to know the girl for like a
week maybe two weeks
ladies send in your dms now two thousand
dollar
no i mean not only that i don't know it
just could be like stupid [ __ ] like
i don't know i'll rent a car or would
you ever like oh he rented a couple cars
to impress girls
wait i think i saw one was it a
lamborghini yeah
you went to the lamborghini how much is
that that's like oh it's gonna be two
grand right
well okay well there's two times i know
three times
wouldn't they know it's rented by the
way like yeah yeah of course
i mean yeah i tell them i'm like this is
a rental okay yeah i'm not like this is
my
car on the first date no no no no no
i gotta rent it again no i mean um yeah
rental is like really expensive
uh i i rented an aventador one time
granted this is like a really cool model
of the method door it's an
svj yeah and it's forty five hundred
dollars a day
so wow yeah that was expensive
a day yeah is your roi on it my roi
you know i don't want to sound like
podcast
was it a good roi yeah pretty good 10
for sure
so that's interesting uh that that is
like a love language
i recently learned that yes that's what
people tell me and give them gifts
is one of them yeah i'm really good at
it oh yeah jack you edited
was that the video yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's like five love language
and that's trying to teach jack would
you guys spend money on stupid
two or might the only one no no a little
bit here and there like what he goes off
yeah so like i mean i don't i wouldn't
consider like i never
like waste my money but i like if i see
you know if i
if i'm at a store and i see like a
uh i don't know if the off the record
there was like
for a thousand dollars i mean it was a
thousand bucks wait wait wait what was
it you did this jack
you must
[Laughter]
you guys are discovering about each
other you've never known yeah
i mean it wasn't terribly expensive it's
been like 30 bucks
you walked by this and you're like that
looks like a good idea
that's what you said wow that's a great
story thank you i mean i've actually
never shared that with that i mean
obviously
like any my parents i mean my parents
are going to probably listen to this
song okay
i'm sure you've had something come on
you gotta open up a little bit of
anything
no you know what this could be turning
into a uh
reviewing your tinder profile oh my gosh
can i see yours oh can we see yours yeah
we see retention
as soon as again jack's dating do you
have tinder do you guys have or
obviously you don't but
do you no i don't i just don't like
dating apps
i just yeah i just don't like dating
apps i just think and i'm like not that
i have anything against them it's just
i'd rather like
reach out to somebody like dm them or
like meet somebody whatever
but yeah i'd love to see yours yeah can
we see yours
oh we get to see all the photos i would
say this is the most like refined
profile did you make any of the changes
from jeanette oh wow you holding
a chicken that's actually a really good
photo i don't know
how to get to messages
we should we should you're the first
person to ever go for messages here's
the thing bro i mean it's going to be
embarrassing
100 but who cares can i just
like look real quickly yeah yeah yeah
don't delete anything what's the name of
the chicken
the chicken's name is edwin that cooking
gets you a lot you can meet him sometime
if you'd like do you have a chicken
it was my friend's that thing got
slaughtered honestly
yeah oh my god this is terrible
so so one day you'd like to meet him
then
she already said yeah absolutely and
then no response
i'm sorry i i don't know what was going
on with that that's not good
terrible how come you keep not
responding uh jack's terrible at that
you just i'm just not bad i'm bad at
texting yeah yeah a lot of girls here
man
you're skipping you're skipping why what
happened i just i
prefer skipped why because you're still
talking with her or what yeah yeah yeah
okay well can you give us that i can
read it to you okay no
i actually don't want to we can't cut it
out though we could do it and then we
could cut it out do it for the
for the podcast come on
no no please
else anything else how bad is it it's
not
bad at the one time bro what do you do
three a week on your main channel three
a week on the main channel that's what
takes the most amount of time
anything else for me uh work wise is a
distraction
so like that's got to be my party three
times a week planning out videos how
many on your family
what's up how many on your family
channel family oh like one week one
but we don't have to worry about that a
lot of that spontaneous like
you fixing the toilet like that's
something we just think it's funny so
we'll film it and
if it if it's usable great if not right
so i'm just kidding that's it um but
uh yeah that that's pretty simple to
film but
we'll purposely wait until we have
something exciting going on is filament
cool but yeah three times a week that's
what takes the most amount of time
gotcha where do you guys ideally want to
go like in life
like five ten years down down the line
uh me personally i wanna have a lot of
different revenue streams and i want
each one of them to be running on their
own right so i'm not
involved in a day to day and i have so
many different ideas throughout the day
and like throughout the month that i
i want to attack but i can't and what i
do is i write them down
and i say to myself like i'll eventually
get to them you know when when i
when this becomes successful and then
when this becomes successful and when i
can detach myself and move on to
something else i like starting different
things
and seeing them grow that's what i want
to do i really just want to be happy
that's are you not no i'm i'm great but
it's so depressing
that's just always been my thing so like
i could i could be farming and
the biggest thing that i learned was the
different revenue streams because i
think like the average millionaire has
six different revenue streams
so once i heard that that's when i
started to really diversify my time of
like don't put every 100
into this like see what else i can do
and that really helped me
um especially when i moved out to los
angeles because it was like a fresh
start
like four or five years ago and that was
my goal to really diversify my time and
it's been really
successful for me doing that so i'd love
to even do that even more
appreciate it thanks for having us yeah
no thank you so much i really appreciate
it guys thank you so much for watching
uh make sure oh you got to tell them to
destroy the like button yes destroy the
like button
and smash it smash it and subscribe and
subscribe
and don't forget to get your free stock
down below in the description it's worth
all up to seventy dollars
hell yeah seventy seventy seven seven
zero yes
seven zero dollars you just gotta sign
up and get it
so thank you guys so much for watching
and one thing i wanna mention that i
don't mention too often in videos is
that we do actually have a mentorship
group down below in the description
where you could meet with me every other
week and you can also talk to jack
every other week as well we do zoom
calls we talk for about an hour an hour
and a half you could ask me whatever
questions you want
it's a really small group so we have a
lot of one-on-one time so if that's
something you're interested in joining
the link is down below in the
description thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time bye guys
see ya
64th ever episode of the ice coffee okay
my name is
ilya and so far the podcast is made okay
so ready yep one three two one